we mentioned earlier that the first lady
of the united states jill biden had
visited unannounced ukraine
today we now have some pictures of that
you can see here
these pictures just released of the
first lady jill biden
with her counterpart a ukrainian
counterpart alessa zielenska meeting
with some kids there at a school in
uzard that's a town near the slovakian
border and that meeting has taken place
earlier today which is mother's day of
course in the u.s mother's day in fact
in large parts of the world just not in
the uk looks like they're with the kids
perhaps they are doing some some form of
arts and crafts related to mother's day
i'm unsure about that but either way
these are the first pictures we have of
the first lady jill biden on her
unannounced surprise visit to oozarod in
ukraine with the first lady of uh
ukraine elena
zelenska and it will of course
also highlight the fact that president
biden has not gone many people
understand why that's uh
of course the case for safety reasons
possibly also because of his own health
but this does highlight that fact coming
a few weeks after the defense secretary
the secretary of state and a
congressional contingent
uh including the speaker of the house
have uh now visited and pretty odd i
would say to see in a war zone the first
lady visit on her own even if it is
mother's day
even if there is a specific peg for the
visit without uh the president of the
united states either going with her or
in advance for a separate uh uh trip but
there we go those pictures uh uh of jill
biden uh the first of the united states
with her ukrainian counterpart alessa
zielinska